Thanks to Skillshare for supporting this episode
of Journey to the Microcosmos.
The first 1,000 people to click the link in
the description can get a free trial of Skillshare’s
Premium Membership.
Recently, we did an episode about sperm, and
in it we talked about the awkward history
of how, at times, humans have overestimated
the role of sperm.
It is true that sperm is essential to human
reproduction.
But the spermist school of thought maintained
that the sperm was where all of the important
information encoding our traits was located.
And the egg, well…the egg was just there
to provide some nourishment.
That point of view was wrong about how genetic
information gets passed along.
But also…it really just underestimated the
engineering marvel that is the egg.
Now, it’s easy to focus on eggs in sexual
reproduction because for humans and many other
animals, the fertilization of the egg by a
sperm is the key step that drives the development
of a new embryo.
And the meeting of sperm and egg is an incredibly
valuable one, allowing organisms to mix and
match genes between individuals so that the
population can better evolve and adapt.
But not all sperm/egg pairings introduce variation.
For example, some flatworms are hermaphroditic,
and under certain conditions, they might fertilize
their own eggs.
In one species, that process involves injecting
sperm directly into their own head.
But also, while all sperm needs an egg, not
all eggs need sperm.
There are quite a few organisms, like many
gastrotrichs and rotifers, that reproduce
by parthenogenesis.
In these species, the female makes an unfertilized
egg that develops and eventually hatches into
a miniature version of its singular parent.
Both self-fertilization and parthenogenesis
come along with the advantage that you do
not have to find a mate, you can just go ahead
and get your own egg going.
And that’s great if you want to grow a large
population or there just aren’t very many
viable mating options around, but it does
come at the cost of genetic diversity.
As an egg develops and the cells within it
divide and differentiate, there is a flurry
of activity to support them.
Developing an organism is an involved process.
It’s not like you have all your materials
laid out in front of you, and all that’s
left is to assemble those pieces.
It’s more like starting out with one brick
and being told to make more bricks from it.
And as you make more bricks from those bricks,
you have to also make them more and more specialized
until you get, like, a castle.
Now, coming up with a comparison inevitably
sells the complexity of the whole process
short.
In rotifer eggs, scientists have found an
uptick in genes involved with cell proliferation,
adhesion, and communication—all of which
makes sense because there is so much coordination
needed to make sure that as cells divide,
they’re talking to each other and assembling
themselves correctly into one of the most
complex structures the universe has ever seen,
a living, multicellular organism.
Now, in addition to everything going on inside
the egg, there’s everything going on in
the world around it.
An egg that has been released into the microcosmos
is subject to the environmental whims of its
surroundings, which makes it all the more
remarkable how many animals produce eggs that
are crafted to wait and survive those conditions
for long periods of time.
Tardigrades, for example, can produce eggs
capable of withstanding extreme heat and extreme
cold, as well as doses of radiation that would
kill a human being.
Those eggs however are different from the
ones that are currently on your screen, which
are hydrated and thus not able to survive
those extremes.
They’re only good at surviving these wild
circumstances when they’ve been desiccated,
or dried out.
Those hardy eggs are called dormant or “resting”
eggs, which makes them sound inert.
And that’s kind of the point: the eggs are
inactive.
Their metabolism essentially shuts down, as
does synthesis of any new DNA, RNA, or proteins.
What the eggs take with them, going into that
state is all that they have to survive, like
an internal desert island.
But it takes a lot of work to make that inactivity
possible.
There are a lot of animals that produce dormant
eggs, and the conditions that drive that dormancy
and the way they emerge from it vary according
to that animals’ lifestyle and environment.
For many rotifer species, resting eggs are
the result of sexual reproduction6.
And an important thing for us to note as you
look at these rotifer eggs: there are morphological
features specific to rotifer resting eggs,
but we are not familiar enough with those
traits to be able to make the call on whether
or not the eggs we’re looking at are resting
or non-resting.
Now, if we had some decades, we might be able
to tell you because that’s how long some
resting eggs can survive.
Some have even hatched after over 100 years
of rest, but alas we definitely do not have
that long to wait.
Even if we’re having a hard time telling
resting and non-resting eggs apart from the
outside, they are very different on the inside.
These protections can be straightforward,
like an abundance of proteins that protect
the egg from heat and oxidative stress.
But on top of protecting cells from external
factors, the resting egg has to be protected
from itself.
In animals, apoptosis--or programmed cell
death-- is a necessary part of our survival.
It helps our bodies clear out cells that are
no longer healthy or necessary.
Without it, you and I would have already died
of cancer.
But a cell in the dessicated, dormant environment
of the resting egg is not going to look very healthy.
So some animals like Artemia have devised
molecular strategies that interfere with the
pathways that lead to apoptosis so that the
cell can be left alive
And alongside the protections are stores of
messenger RNA, also kept at rest and stabilized
while the egg is in stasis.
Those stores of RNA contain the instructions
the egg needs to move quickly when it emerges
from its resting state.
Because, after decades or even a century of
waiting, once it’s time to get going, it’s
TIME TO GET GOING and those instructions will
allow the egg to jump start the synthesis
of the proteins that it will need to grow
and divide and bring new life back to the
microcosmos wherever they have ended up.
Thanks for coming on this journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
We would like to say thank you again to Skillshare
for supporting this video.
Did looking at those eggs make you hungry?
Well, probably not, but once you’ve regained
your appetite, and feel like eating some eggs
again, why not learn how to use them in all
new ways!
You can learn many many things on Skillshare,
including how to cook, and with courses like
“Make Fresh Pasta the Real Italian Way”
you can learn to make fresh pasta using an
egg dough.
Chef Nicoletta Grippo will walk you through
the ins and outs of preparing pasta to perfection
and in the end, you’ll walk away feeling
inspired to cook pasta at home for your family
and friends, who will deeply appreciate it.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning.
With so much to explore, real world projects
to create, and support from fellow-creatives,
Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real
growth.
It’s curated specifically for learning,
meaning there are no ads to distract you,
and they’re always launching new premium
classes, so you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you.
And an annual subscription to Skillshare is
less than $10 a month.
If you’re one of the first 1,000 people
to click the link in the description, you
can get a free trial of Skillshare’s Premium
Membership.
The folks on the screen right now, they are
our patrons on Patreon.
They allow us to go one with these journeys
into the Microcosmos and learn more and then
communicate that learning with you and we’re
so happy to have their support and if would
like to become one of them, you can do that
at patreon.com/journeytomicro
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram, or you can check
out his new book, “The Hidden Beauty of
the Microscopic World”.
Link in the description.
And if you want to see more from us, there
is always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.